[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you heard a rumor yeah they had a rumor
that there was an asian boy in slidell
louisiana which was probably about 17
miles away
and so we had to get over there yeah you
know we were fired up and we
thought about it for a couple weeks and
then we started me until my buddies cut
grass man this kid danny
yeah who was a good friend of mine and
he had some he had a couple of different
deficiencies but he's
he's doing okay now yeah you know and he
um
we raised up some money saved up some
money over about two months
and then we caught a taxi over there
yeah and we
went to this place where they were
supposed to have you know this asian boy
chet i want to say the name was chet i'm
trying to think off
it doesn't sound plausible it does it
doesn't sound plausible because i've
never met an asian guy named chad yeah
there are in southeast asia there you go
it's either um i think it's either thai
or
oh well then chat mate bro chatman
the rumor but so we got there and he
wasn't there it was a uh
it wasn't there it wasn't he wasn't
there
the name is from the city city of
chester england
probably no probably no oh yeah yeah and
uh
yeah we went there and it was just like
a laundromat someone had opened up like
a new laundromat or like a cleaning like
a
right clothing but there was no was it
the asian run laundromat
i don't know that could have been maybe
somehow something that got defused when
it by the time i got tossed
you know i mean this is way pre-internet
yeah right
right this is back when what was the
first do you remember the first time you
ever saw an asian in the flesh
man i feel like it was a man
yeah i feel like it was a man with
glasses on yeah but they didn't i could
probably draw a picture of him but i
don't think that i
i could but i don't think that i could
tell you when like i was in a coma
if i i i i could see that one roma but
you woke up to piss
yeah but i was like a sleeping coma like
walking around como no no
in the bad coma but you get up to peace
and nobody so i'm not in a coma then
there's no coma like that there could be
okay let's just i have this weird
disease where i have a i'm in a coma i
can pee
yeah and and if i think if they call it
the yellow sleep they call it
you know they i've had the yellow sleep
yeah yeah
yeah and it's just yellow because of
peeing not because you're asian
i don't know okay i mean
what you said okay i know but i'm just
saying
that i know but they call it
i know i know but what i'm saying though
is
psychology general so yeah yeah you know
but it's just like oh i just want to say
this is that just don't say yellow
sleeve
okay i [ __ ] what worked all summer to
go see you
when i was a kid and you weren't there
dude huh
the cleaners chat
[Laughter]
you weren't there dude the rumor
revealed revealed but i forgive you bro
yeah i opened a store for two months
and i knew cleo was coming so i closed
it down to me right now i love you
i love you too no i really do love you i
love you too as a human being
and i love you too and does that feel
good or no yeah i believe you you do
believe me yeah
i was lying i was good acting
i don't really have any feelings you're
a piece of [ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah like if you died i
would just be like what
leo died i'd be like oh okay
oh come on let me just move on with my
day i had a friend named brady
he was the neighborhood kid and with one
hand he could
pull a stop sign out of the ground oh
wow gosh he had like a sub human
strength
right and then but he was also kind of
[ __ ] like you you would ask him a
question he wouldn't even know what
you're saying
oh yeah yeah like how how are you and
you go
and you just pull it out of the ground
right yeah but i remember him
i used to use him to break into houses
oh jesus oh wow
because he was to get marijuana oh wow i
would break into people's houses
of mice and marijuana
[Laughter]
you just use a mentally challenged kid
to [ __ ]
that's a funny movie huh yeah let's make
it yeah let's make that movie dude
crowdfund yeah yeah dude we ain't making
[ __ ] dude we're barely gonna [ __ ] get
this episode
[Laughter]
i'm tired of carrying a wallet in my
back pocket because for me it just feels
i don't know
archaic and uncomfortable i don't like
people looking at my back of my pants
and being like oh
is that guy a camel you know look at the
lump in his pants
so now you got to work with that new
front pocket carry and
whoa oh
my god
whoa that was a dark wow dude that's
real it was just crazy they were adults
and this has happened
where do you think honey comes from bro
i know where honey comes from trees
brother
that's sad bro we're talking about sap
dude
i'm not talking about no sap i'm talking
about honeycombs
from the south that's what i got caught
up i got caught up in that sap scandal
dude
oh dude that hit a lot of the southern
u.s bro
when theo doesn't know what he's talking
about he closes his eyes you know
well you could dunk yep at one point do
you know you know i've never made a
basket
i knew that yeah i've never made a
basket
no i i've never that's the truth
what kind of basket are we talking about
because there's no way our asian
audience is believing that you've never
made a basket
no i've made baskets like for the river
and stuff yeah i put fish on you right
but i've never taken a basketball and
thrown it i don't know what that feels
like
you could yeah but i know where honey
comes from
you know so we both win you guys we both
lose
where did you say honey comes from what
was yours honeycomb the woods
yeah in the woods but in honeycomb yeah
honeycomb
yeah where does that come from you cook
you call me you want to call me goo god
you guys edited that in there yes you
did
and we have it on [ __ ] factual files
dude okay
that's not a real thing factual style i
like that
but anyway number 19 bro would get onto
my bicycle right yeah yeah and when he
would see me coming he would say here
comes the
in he would say the n-word bus he would
say here comes the inward bus
oh really and as many blackheads as they
wanted to would get onto my bike
and make me bike them to school like the
little engine that could wow
yeah and i would roll up with like six
black guys
on my bicycle and all i was trying to do
was get to school literally it would be
an extra
seven probably 800 pounds of young man
going
going into fifth to sixth grade wow you
know what i'm saying like
i could see somebody with like a vitamin
deficiency or like severe
you know uh dna deficiency or something
immediately being like a chromosome
deficiency being like oh this is our guy
you know this is our mayor you know this
is our wizard of oz
you don't like that at all a black
friend told me that
uh chinese people are like the black
people of asia is that true or is that
what is that
have you ever heard that dude you should
get your dick tattooed
on your chest
i could see that you don't think
let's take another question what is it
about the curly hair nice eye combo that
just makes everybody will come into that
what about the straight hair slightly
eye
i mean it's an acquired taste brother
you know what i'm saying look if you're
in a plane crash
yeah you are definitely the first one
that's going to get [ __ ]
or eaten [ __ ] or eaten or just oh you
seem like a you seem like the kind of
like little dessert boy that gets kind
of [ __ ] in prison but only around the
holidays you know
oh dude i wonder how you would be in
prison i wonder oh i would be
a walking hole yeah it would just be
look at that
is that a black hole and then they'd
look at my face you know that's bobby's
ass
it would just be dude people would just
be in you have to carry your ass in both
sides like in
each hand you would just walk around
with your own ass with the cheeks
yeah yeah with the eye like yeah like
it's a dress
like i'm bowing at like a ball yeah
curtsy
yeah but those are my ass cheeks
yeah i think that i would i'd be a bat
flies out of it
right right but people are telling ghost
stories outside of it with a lantern
[Laughter]
that's funny but i think that like if
you saw my cell though
yeah i'd have stacks of cigarettes oh
yeah right i have all the wine
like i have all the things because i'm
going to barter
yeah i'm going to potter for my butthole
oh yeah dude
yeah he's a little vest that says it
right yeah but i bet i bet after a while
right get your motor right yeah
dude if you were my friend i know you
wouldn't i probably would have put you
in like one of those little wagons you
know
there's red wagons yeah i know the right
way yeah that's a chinese buddy on the
side of it
and i would hook you to my bike dude and
do all around town oh that's nice it's
kind of cool so it's
like you you have a rickshaw for me yeah
[Music]
yeah and then i just go ah chinese yeah
all right that would be fun
parade or bow at people and stuff people
throw you beads through your chocolates
yeah yeah you eat them bro right like
i'm a deity oh yeah
that's really nice and we go on a big
chocolate ride every day and you [ __ ]
just get all the [ __ ] chocolates and
sweets and people come out and wish you
well and give you baked goods
yeah yeah forehead too that's very
cavemen like is it really he has bangs
how can
[Music]
we had this dude named brian uh brian
purvis the first wiga ever
you know and they don't have them
anymore they have a couple left i think
outside of maybe
cincinnati but he was like
the first white kid that ever wanted to
be black and they'd never seen it before
and they put him in a mentally
handicapped classes because they thought
he was mentally handicapped
mentally challenged is that what they
used to do with wiggers uh yeah yeah
yeah well they didn't know they'd never
seen it before yeah they put him in
there wow
so they had people that were really you
know people that were just
you know didn't know what was going on
yeah deaf people blind people that were
you know freebase victims all kind of
stuff like that and then you just had
brian's
uh purvis just dribbling an invisible
basketball
just wearing a [ __ ] charlotte hornets
pullover
starter pullover apex and just [ __ ]
you know
blowing menthols and [ __ ]
oh man we don't know what he has you
know is brian's still an institution or
he's out no he's out somebody sent me a
picture of the other day i think he's in
prison somewhere he's in jail or in or
out of jail just more it smells like
there's more kind of hidden animals in
here why
why right right the night you think that
i have them as pets or other things
i don't know yeah yeah i think you i can
imagine you've been through a lot with
different animals
but i um i'm happy to be here man i
appreciate you having me yeah
i love animals and i love you i've
always loved you man um i don't know
when i met you when did i meet you
um trying to look at how big you were
whenever we met probably
same size so probably maybe six years
ago yeah
yeah seven or eight in a long time
[Music]
i
[Music]